two things really made me angry about
this
one
it was not offensive uh interference it
just was not they were both go they were
both competing for for the ball it was a
good competitive football play late in
the game and i hate to say late in the
game because that doesn't really matter
to me when mike mccarthy said after the
game you don't call that in that point
that's that's beside the point mike i'm
on your side but if it's a bad play if
it's egregious and it happens with 30
seconds left or 15 seconds left go ahead
and call that if it's a penalty but it
wasn't a penalty that's one thing that
made me angry the other thing that made
me angry
afterwards mike is hearing tony karente
the official
say
oh it was obvious listen you part-time i
don't know what to do in your full-time
job you're not a full-time official most
of them aren't
you part-time official
you're gonna try to tell me it's obvious
what they should do michael smith is go
back if they're not going to because we
can't use replay on
interference because the officials are
too sensitive about it they're too
insecure
so even when it's obvious that they make
a mistake they never call it they never
reverse their own call what we need to
do
is have somebody new either somebody
neutral in the booth
to review it automatically
it's too important to play mike it's 47
yards
it's a game changer play i feel you i
and i appreciate your passion let me
tell you something
in 20 years in this business of doing
stuff like this having these kinds of
conversations yeah i have never
manufactured a take
just to manufacture a tape i am not one
of these hey
we're gonna disagree i'm gonna take this
side and you take that side people
that's not what i do that is not what i
do okay i call you out on this i'm not
gonna call you out
i won't do it so i am not being
contrarian when i say this
wasn't that bad
wasn't that awful i didn't it's what it
wasn't awful it wasn't it was look could
it have gone either way tell me why it
wasn't that bad it was that was pretty
bad
jaylen ramsey has a lot of tools in his
toolkit he sold the hell out of it he
sold the hell out of it like part of
being a part of being a db
there's a little bit of acting involved
it looked like gallup created
substantial enough separation they were
hand fighting the whole way down and
gallup has a right to get to get jaylen
ramsey off him but when gallup extended
ever so much and look when when uh when
jalen did that
that he sold it give him credit for
selling it that's what that's what got
the penalty look i mean i guess it's
because i've just seen so many
egregious past interference calls so
it's like it's not a it's a blocked
charge it's not a surprise to me if
somebody gets it wrong i just thought
that by the letter of the law in terms
of using extending your arm to create
separation jalen ramsey sold it enough
to make it look like just that they
should i agree with that they should let
it go but i have a hard time painting
outrage about it like oh my god they got
robbed so words call ever like eh you
know it's like okay you know i i get it
that's you know that's kind of where i'm
at with it
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports